يعد السودان اغنى الدول العربيه
والافريقيه نظرا لثروه الزراعيه
والحيوانيه والمعدنيه فضلا عن انه اكبر
بلد في العالم انتاجا للصمغ العربي ولا
يقتصر تصنيف السودان في هذا الجانب على
المستوى الاقليمي فحسب بل ان هذه الثروات
تجعله في مصافي الدول العالم الغنيه
بالموارد الطبيعيه
وفقا لبيانات البنك المركزي السوداني يصل
حجم المساحات الصالحه للزراعه في السودان
الى 200 مليون فدان لكن المزروع منها 64
مليون فقط وهو ما يمثل نحو الثلث وتشكل
المراعي الطبيعيه 115 مليون فدان اما حجم
هطل الامطار فيقدر بنحو 400 مليار متر
مكعب سنويا ويصنف السودان بانه يمتلك سادس
اكبر ثروه حيوانيه في العالم تناهز مئه
وعشره ملايين راس من المواشي حسب احصائيات
وزاره الثروه
والسمكيه كما تظهر بيانات الوزاره ان
الصيد البحري يوفر للبلاد نحو 42 الف طن
من الاسماك سنويا وفي مساجد الموارد
المعدنيه يقدر احتياطي الذهب بالف
وخمسمائه وخمسين طنا وفقا لبيانات وزاره
المعادن كما ان السودان ثالث اكبر منتج في
افريقيا للمعدن النفيس بعد غانا وجنوب
افريقيا وبلغ حجم الانتاج العام الماضي 93
طنا في حين تقدر احتياطيات الفضه في 1500
طن مع خمسه ملايين طن من النحاس ومديون
ونصف المليون طن من اليورانيوم اكثر من
ذلك تشير بيانات مجلس الصمغ العربي
السوداني لان السودان يستحوذ على نحو 80%
من انتاج الصمغ العربي في العالم
والصمغ العربي منتج يدخل في اكثر من 180
صناعه في القطاعات الغذائيه والدوائيه
والكيميائيه اضافه الى صناعه زجاج
والالوان لكن حصه السودان من تجارته
العالميه لا تتجاوز عشره في المئه بسبب
التهريب واحتكار الشركات المحليه وعالميه
تفرض اسعارها على المنتجين ويبلغ الانتاج
السنوي للصمغ العربي 120 الف طن لكن
امكانيات الغابات تتيح انتاج نصف مليون طن
سنويا كما ينتج السودان
39% من الانتاج العالمي من السمسم الابيض
وثلاثه وعشرين في المئه من السمسم الاحمر
غير ان هذه الثروات لم تستغل لاستغلال
كاملا من استقلال البلاد عن الاحتلال
البريطاني في عام
ويعزى السبب للمشكلات السياسيه والعسكريه
التي تعصف بالسودان منذ استقلاله وتباطؤ
وتيره نمو الاقتصادي والتفاقم الديون
الداخليه والخارجيه وفقدان 75%
من الموارد النفطيه نتيجه انفصال الجنوب
في عام 2011